Es como una gran caja. Esto es a lo que se parece.
Y esto es entre yo y las ballenas,
y a veces eso se siente como un muro entre tú y la realidad.
¿Hay alguna diferencia cuando es su teléfono?
El año pasado, fui a Uluru en el centro de Australia,
que es esta roca masiva que se eleva sobre el desierto.
Esta es la tierra sagrada para los anagu,
los aborígenes de este área,
y los propietarios tradicionales de esta tierra.
Hay lugares particulares en Uluru que no puede fotografiar profesionalmente
porque son culturalmente sensibles,
equivalentes a las sagradas escrituras para los anangu.
Debido a esto, la mayoría de mis fotos son desde muy lejos, como esta,
o desde ángulos específicos en el parque.
Se podría decir que algunas de las imágenes más interesantes
y bellas en Uluru
están localizadas en estas áreas sensibles,
pero la petición de no fotografiarlos es una invitación explícita y directa
para aprender más sobre la tierra, su importancia y su gente.
¿No es lo que deberíamos estar haciendo?
Así que mi visita a Uluru rápidamente no era sobre mí
sino sobre conectar con el lugar.
Irónicamente y como era de esperar,
he encontrado esa presencia y conexión
también resulta en crear imágenes más atractivas.
Probablemente todos podemos señalar a las redes sociales
como un buen lugar para compartir imágenes de nuestros viajes y vidas.
No solo podemos compartir partes del mundo que hemos visto
sino también partes de nuestras experiencias diarias.
Y si estamos aplicando intencionalidad a las fotos que tomamos,
entonces esperamos compartirlas también intencionalmente.
Para mí, permitir que la gente vea partes de mi historia y perspectiva online
me recuerda que no estoy sola.
Me ayudó a construir apoyo y comunidad
para hacer lo mismo por otros.
Permítame clarificarlo:
no estoy tratando de desanimarlos para que no tomen fotos.
Incluso si miles de personas han estado en cualquier ubicación exacta
y han tomado cualquier foto exacta,
les animo a salir y crear también.
El mundo necesita cada voz y perspectiva,
y las suyas incluidas.
Pero lo que intento mostrarle es que el teléfono o cámara
no tienen que estar fuera todo el tiempo.
Lo que trato de alentarles a hacer
es guardarlos, solo por un momento,
un momento para Uds.
Así que volvamos a Mesa Arch,
la forma en que la roca brilla naranja
y las hermosas capas de azul en el fondo.
¿Y si la próxima vez que estuvieran en un lugar increíble
no pudieran llevar su cámara o su teléfono?
¿Qué pasaría si no le permitieran tomar ninguna fotografía?
¿Se sentiría como una limitación?
¿O se sentiría como un alivio?
¿Qué podemos hacer?
Bueno, la próxima vez que sientan el impulso de sacar su cámara o teléfono
o, en mi caso, una vez que se hayan dado cuenta de que ya la sacaron...
(Risas)
Primero, paren.
Pausa.
Tómense un respiro.
Miren alrededor. ¿Qué perciben?
¿Están experimentando este momento con otra persona?
Recuerden que este momento solo llega una vez.
La fotografía puede ser parte de una bella experiencia.
No dejen que sea un muro entre Uds. y la realidad.
Vean el sentido
y no pierdan un recuerdo bello, irremplazable,
por estar muy concentrados en conseguir la fotografía.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)